hi there it's a bit of a dreary day
today i gotta go out and run some
errands
um
recently there's been discussion
i think on my youtube channel and on our
forum at link
about the methods that luca
lamporiello uses and he is an
outstanding learner
uh there are some a number of things
that we agree on number of things we
don't agree on but two things that i'm
going to look into in greater detail are
one his
uh he seems to like gasimil a lot
and he also has this method of
translating from the target language
into his own and back again and i'm
gonna do some more uh investigating
these so i ordered up let's have a look
here see if we can get this i ordered up
some
asi mil here
uh for uh romanian and uh checks i'm
gonna open this up
and
see if i understand perhaps a bit better
what their method is and i might even
get some or get an sml for vietnamese
when i started the vietnamese later on
i goofed
all i got was the books i didn't get the
cds no wonder it was so cheap
uh i'm gonna have to order the cds for
these
and maybe i'll order them at the same
time as i order my vietnamese yeah it
was 23 euros per book
that's a lot less than it used to be my
recollection was that these
uh assimil
systems cost a lot of money i checked
just now on the internet on the the
vietnamese with cds is something like 60
euros that's a lot of money
that's a lot of money uh for a starter
book i might just go back to teach
yourself
anyway i'll look through these and
report back later